il ne semble pouvoir ralentir sa course
l'avion en bas celle-ci de Vaci puis
touche le sol
les secouristes et les curieux
s'activent autour de l'épave enflammée
l'écrasement dans un ravin n'a laissé
aucune chance aux 68 passagers et 4
membres de l'équipage on a bien tenté
d'éteindre le brasier mais le mal était
fait
l'opération de sauvetage s'est adhérer
très difficile souligne ce policiers
plus d'une centaine de militaires ayant
participé 6 enfants se trouvaient à bord
de l'appareil
une véritable tragédie se désole le
Premier ministre du Népal qui a convoqué
son cabinet pour une réunion d'urgence
la tr72 un avion de ligne du
transporteur Yeti Airlines partez de la
capitale Katmandou puisse s'est écrasé
près de l'atterrissage au nouvel
aéroport de Pokhara inaugurie le 1er
janvier 2023 cette destination est
courue tant par les pèlerins que les
randonneurs parmi les passagers 15
ressortis sans étranger
cette dernière tragédie en fait la plus
meurtrière en 30 ans au Népal ici
Jean-Philippe Radio-Canada Montréal